[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
brazil bienvenue au pays qui vit et
respire au rythme du football
à manaus porto d'entrée de l'amazonie on
en n'est pas en reste non plus avec le
ballon rond
c'est ici qu'a lieu tous les ans le
pelada au plus grand concours amateur de
foot du monde pendant six mois
sept cents équipes s'affrontent aux
quatre coins de la ville
mais à manaus le football n'a pas le
monopole des rondeurs
[Musique]
à l'autre bout de la ville répète les
filles qui font duper la dao une
compétition à part hors norme
car le paie la dao n'est pas qu'un
tournoi de foot c'est aussi un concours
de beauté
un véritable hymne à la vie qu'on doit
sans doute un peu à la moiteur du climat
[Musique]
et au bout du compte on ne sait plus
très bien qui supporte dit nez qui
supporte quoi chaque équipe a sa reine
et chaque rehn qui passe les
éliminatoires peut repêcher son équipe
en cas de défaite en me faufilant dans
les vestiaires je choisis ma reine erika
c'est elle que je vais suivre et son
équipe à l'occasion de ce week-end
marathon des quarts de finale où bell et
sportif concours en parallèle un jour
mon frère m'a appelé pour me demander si
j'accepterai d'être la reine de son
équipe
je suis allé voir l'entraîneur ils m'ont
trouvée jolie et j'ai été sélectionné
pour défendre leurs couleurs
c'est une belle expérience
et puis j'aimerais bien gagner le
premier prix c'est une voiture c'est
toujours bon ce que j'espère c'est
d'avancer le plus possible dans la
compétition qui comprend chaque fois les
plus loin j'aimerais savoir pourquoi
dans le pays la da ou les jolie fille se
met au service du ballon et pas l
inverse
je me rends sur les rives du fleuve pour
retrouver arnal dos santos organisateurs
de la compétition qui arbitre ce
journaleux match des futurs champions le
ballon a toujours été la chose la plus
importante de ma vie
le ballon pour moi a été comme un
biberon je dirais même comme le sein de
ma mère
le thé la dao est né de l'idée de
rassembler les familles dans les rues et
de les faire jouer entre elles faire la
fête et comme on ne peut pas faire la
fête sans l'accord de la mère et fille
des amis des voisines mais ce qu'ils
amis sans l'accord des femmes et comme
ici en amazonie la femme depuis la nuit
des temps est au coeur de nos traditions
alors on a décidé de les intégrer dans
notre compétition
le p la dao est une compétition
brésilienne mais surtout amazonienne on
a simplement troqué l'arc et les flèches
contre un ballon était crampons et les
canons de beauté à quelques évolutions
prêts restent les mêmes ici une belle
femme
c'est une indienne avec des formes
généreuses des cheveux noirs aussi long
qu'un possible et on pose chocolat qu'on
voudrait croquer
il est midi eric et avec son équipe ont
rendez vous avec le destin
l'une se préparent à défiler l'autre a
joué l issue de la journée on saura qui
poursuit vers les demi finales pour
l'heure ce sont les impressions d'avant
match l'entraîneur avec ses joueurs
erika chez elle je suis confiant je sais
juste un petit peu nerveuse j'ai le
ventre qui commence à se nouer mais je
suis sûr que ça va aller mieux
aujourd'hui on joue à domicile donc
l'équipe adverse va devoir se mettre à
genoux et implorer notre pardon
[Musique]
si je ne vienne pas cette année
j'essaierai encore mais je ne
m'arrêterai pas je ne laisserai pas
tomber seconde mi temps
erica est partie des filets et un joueur
est tombé
mais nous on veut pas être des héros on
veut juste participer et s'il n'y avait
que moi on n'en serait pas là
tu devrais aller voir ma femme c'est
elle la président du club je lui dois
tout
[Musique]
j'ai retrouvé marilou à l'école du
quartier
le seul endroit où le petit écran
parvenait à capter
on ne regardait pas le match mais on
attendait erika qui défilait en direct
sur la chaîne locale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur le plateau les filles exposer leurs
plus belles courbes elle se regardait ce
sujet la tension était palpable
erika sur une faute de style fut
éliminée
chez marie lou on avait passé le cap des
réjouissances ce n'est pas ce que
j'espérais mais en participant on sait
qu'on est là pour gagner ou pour perdre
mon coeur est triste naturellement parce
qu'on a beaucoup travaillé pour en
arriver là
maintenant il faut que l'équipe de foot
gagne si dieu le veut et il valait
vouloir retour sur le match et ce dieu
qui a fait en sorte qu'il y ait faute à
ce moment précis je n'en sais rien ce
qui me semble pourtant évident
maintenant c'est que le jour où dieu
créa la femme
il jouait au foot 1 0 l'équipe à gagner
et ses sélectionnés pour les demi
finales sans sa reine
[Musique]
mais le paie la dao c'est la vie